[Music]
and beheaded blocks news how do you
think you're doing
submitted by stinky tofu which is
[ __ ] delicious I know you love it you
[ __ ] yeah yeah no way
I didn't know you like that yeah I am
originals are refugees I am a monkey's
ass is all I beg to that [ __ ] space I
really love it
everyone here you guys everyone that
loves eating stinky tofu loves eating it
IBS and I can't eat anything you don't
[ __ ] could you told me can you eat
there in during it why do you keep
leader eat out dairy inside a black
Billiton nom nom you mean bar later come
on no one ever corrected me for less
twenty eight hundred years my lon
no it's because you're smart and people
think they're dumb but like oh it's
Koreans even [ __ ] everyone else
Korean Dracula [ __ ] durian durian is the
real render him durian [ __ ] you went to
a durian specific market you got a color
and that [ __ ] was okay but I don't think
I'll do it again in long different here
I love you're welcome durian is like
this it's basically a stronger jackfruit
yeah also a big [ __ ] garlic mango is
what it is a garlic bagel that exactly
has a very good description Isis famed
counterfeit LEGO sets are being exported
from China cut damage China Isis deemed
like oh I want to be smart about that
like a 911 Lego kit I wouldn't be
surprised you like to Twin Towers of
Swing yeah little airplanes
that is crazy yeah so as Ben found out
that in Malaysia they're selling these
Isis themed Lego like counterfeit Legos
that juice in China yes oh well they
trace the serial number back to a
factory line of course yeah
and so because people were like we
[ __ ] hate it it was a mom and a
teacher a mom who is also a teacher who
found out that her son was playing with
this this set how did she find out that
her son who bought it for her yeah do
they play it knowing like I don't think
you know what Isis is like oh cool war
people like I don't know binges while
she's claiming that uh they purchased it
for two dollars but she didn't realize
it was in the set and that's her I never
mind
sometimes times because I feel like
eight year old kids playing Grand Theft
Auto in their peers like oh I don't know
I think about like dude your kids
playing a game with hookers and speeding
them up and robbing people with you
idiot that's pretty good training I
think what's wrong with you yes nothing
look like I want my kids to learn about
the street Falcon commando it was like
Darth Vader they don't know any better
in Tibet yeah so you know what Isis oh
yeah I all might draw it was an actual
person designing all of this [ __ ]
yeah and then turning to it or not I
just [ __ ] copying like screenshot II
and copying and putting it the toys like
everyone keeps talking about this we
need to make money on this on the news
all about it is hey you think it's a guy
that under the point maybe no I think
they know that it is because well I have
them against the actual Street Fighter
versus fine to in the middle shoes yeah
I know the copy the Street Fighter
fought with the [ __ ] and then down here
if you look closely there's at the
headed whoa-ho-ho I know there's this
other guy races are so insensitive to
holding a chainsaw oh my god
right there is a head [ __ ] you wanna
matching these cuts this proves that
China would do anything to make money
China come on you're probably like
what's the big deal you know counter
side you have terrorist versus anti
terrorist come on same thing let's just
make a real me no I don't think that you
know what we should make this because
kid's gonna want it this cell here knows
what Isis I can't believe is of a headed
person on the gun you know it's because
we're looking at it from the American
lens right because Chinese people are
thinking who clear we make we make the
police for the American and then we make
Isis for this for the middle-eastern
come on let's do it
or maybe I
says contracted of manufacturers in
China Oh kind of brainwashing baby push
it on the children because there's no
water see Nazis actually did that
there's there's a recently this was
[ __ ] Holocaust JUSA and they put all
the [ __ ] the Blago people into a oven
and it closed the door I'll come on a
little game was but recently there was
discovered that there was all this Nazi
memorabilia that was being hidden
somewhere in Brazil and one and there
were actually like toys for children
harmonicas rolled it yeah like rattles
they were like rattles I had like this
monster Ghana I wanna see what other
toys actually makes this is the
pedophilia Edition and it's like all
these like priests why is it always wife
pedo and [ __ ] like that coming out of
your mouth only if he's not pedo bar
he's liberal or because he's free with
his jokes and he's liberal he's
open-minded do I want to close parts of
those mines okay I need a closed part I
like our idea to the Yulin Dog festival
they go for sure that's a good one I
want to see all the toys business the
Japanese dolphin slaughter said right oh
my god
the old clothing services the Hurricane
Katrina said all the houses are down and
broken and all the crying America if you
push a button it spins be quite as a
matching massacre set you see all of our
people die oh no that's [ __ ] crazy do
that all parts of tragic history and I
know later on you know what is so
[ __ ] funny too because like I want to
be in their [ __ ] meetings yeah water
draining because they'll do this right
but then a MMA guy beating up a Taichi
masters like what are your thoughts
blasphemous yeah you are messing with a
culture we don't have I have heard about
that he'd beat up a Tai Chi master yeah
yeah because I got me yeah why the [ __ ]
they even do it when they were fighting
he fell asleep
when one of the Tai Chi master say about
him gang he said he it was his shoes
like a split himself no it's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] is going easy on him
because if he uses real Thai Chi
are you would have died yeah just like
all of kungfu you know what ideas did
what to other ideas of that idea beat
out don't work in bikinis or Rossetti
like a 10 a 10 B Plan C I this is just
way too good men in the board meetings
give me something more current you guys
all have all these medieval ideas give
me something about today more today are
more original so how about a chump set
no no no nobody gonna buy that except
American I know how about the terraces
tell me more obviously it's not real
like a suit like Canada yeah Michael
themselves with mega smegal man I go
it's so hard to go through jeez it's so
hard to differentiate because they
copied to the [ __ ] teeth [ __ ]
copycat is just like the most so crazily
incentive ok attention it details crazy
or even up a heading and then you get
there what the complimentary machete and
then you get like oh so the
manufacturing part of it on my fine I
can see trying to put the the
originality the touch a detail the
attention to detail is not Chinese to me
so what's out there right it's not
reassuring that Chinese would me it's
not Chinese I think it was I think was
probably Isis that like Commission
dollars well what I thought that so they
have Isis graphic designer and a toy
maker and inventor you have an Isis
[ __ ] editor and still doing work of
course so they send them over to China
for quality control
it's an email pro 2017 this is the first
time China has an original idea I think
we should just give it to them I'm not
gonna mention China yeah Manila's coffee
this is original iMac another logo it's
such a pipe from Michael's local I know
it's a go oh my god I wonder if I have
played with Legos today if it would
still be fun I've never played a photo
they're awesome love Legos I think I
think I be I'd have fun building it I
wasn't really not the imagination that
you have as a kid like when you build it
and after you build it and then you
become a part of the piece I don't
I could do that anymore oh yeah because
when you when you play what toy to the
kid like you're in the [ __ ] world you
ya gone in and now you're this like guy
in here you're destroying all this [ __ ]
and then you're [ __ ] each other up and
then you can like play both roles at the
same time it's pretty crazy I know I
want to find all the drawings than I
drew as a kid just to see how far my
imagination went because I remember I
used to draw cards with rocket launchers
and like [ __ ] like gun turrets on top
if somebody would fly ya like em that's
just really heavy but I've never thought
about as a kid and my mind could do
whatever yeah I want to see all those
drawings and I do like to do rap with
like an elephant face every time travel
often so have a relevant this continue
to facing backlash oh for sure facing
backlash I'm not sure if there are any
clothes are just cutting off
distribution of Malaysian flight
everywhere else yeah currently they're
also selling them in Australia whoa how
do you [ __ ] kangaroos are after
something crazy
these are our hosts this is a smallpox
edition the bubonic plague set what's up
you sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] link to
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]
you
[Music]